All right, we have very important breaking news
today, and it's it's actually not all bad news.
The coronavirus vaccine from Pfizer and biotech
has been approved for emergency use in the United
Kingdom. And this is a huge deal for a number of
different reasons. Some obvious, some may be less
obvious to people who are planning to get the
vaccine, because you need to understand what's
going on in the mind of the anti vaccines in order
to understand some of the relevance here. So I'll
explain it all to you. So first and foremost,
the vaccine approved in the U.K. for emergency
use. This first vaccine is the same vaccine that
was submitted for approval in the United States
made by Pfizer and biotech, German and
American companies. The FDA is meeting
next week to decide on emergency use approval
here in the United States as well. In the U.K.,
their own agency, the Medicines and Health Care
Products Regulatory Agency, which licenses drugs
in the United Kingdom, looked at the trial
data. As you know, the trial data indicates
that this vaccine is 95 percent effective at
generating immunity to the coronavirus and said,
yes, the data is good, let's start vaccinating
people. Now, it is still going to be labeled
experimental until final testing is done.
This is similar to here in the U.S. If the FDA
approves it next week, I believe they are meeting
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, next week, or maybe
right, right around that time in the U.S. it
would be given an emergency use authorization,
not a full approval equivalent situation happening
in the U.K. The U.K. now expects 800000 doses
within days and they expect people to be receiving
the vaccine really as soon as that happens,
potentially Monday in the U.K., they are talking
about this is happening. And it is a really,
really big deal. It is the start of and it is
going to be a long tunnel, but we are starting
to see the light at the end of the tunnel. Now,
this vaccine different than the Moderna vaccine,
the Pfizer biotech vaccine requires storage
at minus 70 degrees Celsius. So it's believed
that all of the initial vaccination in the UK is
going to be happening at hospitals that already
have or were able to set up the equipment to
store vaccines at that cold temperature. Now,
the reasons that this is so important, some
are obvious and some are not so obvious.
We need a vaccine and this is a 100 year global
pandemic with what in the US is soon to be a 9/11
a day in terms of deaths. We need a vaccine.
And so this is huge. But the reason that this
is also important, specifically because the UK has
done this, is that there are people in the US who
are not necessarily anti vaccine in general, but
they're worried about the safety of a vaccine that
is simply approved when Donald Trump is president.
The idea being that any agency, including the FDA,
could maybe be influenced by Donald Trump
into approving something that should not yet
be approved. Now, we've heard from Anthony Fauci
that that's not the case. Once it became clear
that despite Donald Trump's pleading in July,
August and September, none of the pharmaceutical
companies developing vaccines pushed for approval
before the election. I was increasingly reassured
that we're not going to see haphazard, rushed
approval requests from pharmaceutical companies.
But if you were still worried about that, we
now have a different country's health regulatory
agency that has said this same vaccine is OK to
use. So the point is, if you just don't trust
the FDA under Trump, even if Trump is now a lame
duck and is unlikely to still be pushing them to
do anything they shouldn't do, you can say I'm
going to go by the British health regulatory
agencies decision soon. We're expecting the same
thing from the U.S. Health Regulatory Agency. It's
the same vaccine, the Pfizer biotech vaccine. And
here in the US as soon as next weekend. I spoke to
a doctor recently on the West Coast who said
we have been told expect to get vaccinated
maybe next weekend or just a couple of days
after that. This is a major achievement. Pfizer
says it can produce 80 million doses this
year, which would be for 40 million people
and one point three billion doses next year, which
would be enough for six hundred and fifty million
people. Remembering that you need two doses.
This is needed acutely. The numbers in the US are
brutal. We've not yet even seen the impact of
the millions and millions of people who traveled
for Thanksgiving to gather indoors and
then travel home. And we still had. Day
two thousand six hundred and fourteen deaths
yesterday, we saw the most deaths in a single day
dating all the way back to April 21st. And
within days, we are expecting to absolutely
blow through those numbers. Within a week, we
could see the most deaths in a single day of
the entire pandemic. We are very close to
a 9/11 worth of deaths every single day.
Now, the ship has sailed on convincing a
huge part of this country about how serious
this is. And the tragedy is that lots of those
same people who refuse to behave responsibly
also aren't interested in a vaccine. And we're
going to have to figure out how we deal with
that. I don't know the answer. As I spoke about
with Congressman Rokan yesterday, these vaccines
initially will not be given to children. So if you
look at our population, bearing in mind we need
about 70 percent immunity for herd immunity, that
means close to every adult has to be vaccinated
for herd immunity. Given that children will
not be eligible for vaccines initially,
this is an uphill battle and the tragic irony of
the people demanding everything go back to normal
right away, those are the same people refusing to
do the things that would actually help us to get
back to normal. So great news from the U.K. We're
keeping an eye on whether we will get a press
conference from the FDA next week announcing their
decision about this same Pfizer biotech vaccine.
And we will we will make every effort to cover
that press conference live, if indeed it happens.